à première vue rien ne distingue ce
dimanche des autres le long des plages
de saint denis de la réunion les
pêcheurs les sportifs et les promeneurs
profitent des vents chauds venus de la
mer et pourtant l'île entière retient
son souffle dans cet hôpital
un petit garçon de 10 ans est
vraisemblablement mort à cause du virus
chikungunya dans les couloirs des
urgences de nombreuses personnes qui en
présente les symptômes
la plupart parfait e avec un traitement
mais quand cela se complique
ils sont transférés dans ce service de
crise 20 lits improvisé pour lutter
contre le virus
presque tous occupés trouver 25 30
places qui étaient faire 35 en période
de crise a été là la limite maximum que
nous pouvions faire si jamais l'épidémie
devaient flamber à ce moment là bien
entendu y trouver des solutions externes
vital on ne pourrait plus réagir nous
sommes aux limites de l'élasticité du
système heureusement le personnel
médical venus de métropole offrent à
l'hôpital une aide précieuse mais depuis
quelques jours le nombre de cas de
chikungunya explose littéralement
j'ai fait une forte fièvre à 40° et
jeudi matin je suis tombé carrément dans
les pommes je suis resté une heure et
demie avec des douleurs en dessous les
pieds dans les mains en ce dans les
poignets mais chikungunya s'attaque
aussi aux nouveaux nés dans ce service
de réanimation pédiatrique
plusieurs d'entre eux luttent contre un
virus que leur maire leur a
involontairement transmis une évolution
de la maladie qui n'avait encore jamais
été constaté par les médecins et qui
leur complique la tâche
ce qui est difficile pour nous c'est de
gérer
en direct la découverte de nouveaux 600
références passées un des biographies
ancien le traitement deux enfants le
virus du chikungunya frappe la réunion
depuis plusieurs mois mais ces derniers
jours l'évolution d'une maladie encore
largement méconnu des scientifiques et
la mort dans cet hôpital d'un petit
garçon ont plongé la population dans
l'inquiétude